we got a request from a group of aligned
dancers in
rockaway new jersey check it out
we're a group of friends from rockaway
new jersey who love to go out line
dancing
we love our girls nights out because
they keep us sane it's great exercise
super fun
and a huge stress relief we absolutely
love you
and your show and our dream is to have
you join us for girls night out of blind
dancing
and good times
well after seeing that video we reached
out to line dancing of rockaway and they
sent their best instructor to teach us
how to dance please welcome samantha
yannick
hi drew it's so fabulous to meet you
thanks for having us
put on my tightest jeans for you you
look fabulous thank you
you're rocking the full denim sucking it
in like nobody's business
well you're rocking it thank you see you
you come out you look effortless like
how's it going um okay now you know
i have to admit i've only been line
dancing once and i really
like didn't have anyone to teach me what
is line dancing
and how did it get started so line
dancing is pretty much it's an organized
set of steps typically by eight counts
and you're all standing in a line with
your friends doing the same steps
having a good time and you're all doing
the same choreographed moves
um so i'm excited to learn today but
what fun is line dancing without a
partner
rossy you there
ladies my jeans are so tied through
never in my life do not drop anything
because i can't pick it up
it's like spanx by wrangler i wish
i might be on to something there full
denim spanx by wrangler
right yeah well ross and i were inspired
to bring it for you
uh and um samantha okay so now that
we're dressed the part
teach us how to do this we're your
students now
beautiful beautiful so the dance we're
doing it's going to start by walking
we're going to be walking are we facing
this way just pardon me
and we're walking okay so weights on our
left foot okay
right yep we're taking three steps
forward walk forward right
walk left walk right kick your left foot
forward kick
we're not going to walk straight back
three steps walk back left
walk back right walk back left touch
your right toe next to it there's no
weight
so you're right back where you started
from oh yeah do the same exact thing
again three steps forward walk right
left right kick back left right
left touch that's half your dance that's
happiness
drew are we are we natural
all right the next piece step touches
they're exactly what they sound like
step forward on your right foot
touch your left toe kind of to the side
touch there's no weight on it step
forward on your left
point your right do them again step
forward right okay point your left
okay step forward left point your right
i can do that
yeah okay yeah okay let's try let's try
it from
the top there's only one piece left
wait's on our left remember it starts
with the walks
ready with the right it's right left
right
kick back left right left touch again
right
left right kick back left right
left touch step step point step
step point step hey nice
i saw it i thought i saw it santa you're
such a good teacher
you guys are great students oh thank you
let's finish it shall we
yeah all right all right quarter turn
jazz box sounds way more fancy than it
is i know
is it like the one is it like a box step
yes
okay we're making a turn to our right
when we do it so take that right foot
cross it over
step back on your left foot making that
turn if you didn't quite make it step
the right foot out to the side
you're done step the left foot together
the last bit of the dance we get to
shake it
bump your hips right left right left
okay i just want to shake it all right
uh tony would you hit us with a little
um music
please and thank you gonna be faster
go right left right kick back back back
up
right straight kick back tuck step one
point
point step point
[Applause]
it was faster that was you didn't
prepare me for that surprise
all right one more time you count us out
samantha okay
okay thank you all right wait it's on
our lips okay one
three five six seven eight it's right
left right kick back left right left
touch walk right
left right kick back left right left
touch we step
point step point step point now right
over left
cross turn side step shake it shake it
shake it stop okay
thank you okay thank you for giving us a
beat
that wasn't you know like a jack rabbit
on steroids okay
thank you so much i mean of course that
was really fun
i know right okay on a scale of one to
ten where do we lie
on the natural at line dancing honestly
you guys are up there you guys are i
would give you a 10.
okay thank you so much samantha you are
so kind
we got a 10 drew all right so we're not
so bad andrew i invited the lion dancing
group from that video
to watch us today hello
how are
[Applause]
how'd we do thumbs up
i thank you so much ladies
for allowing us to come into your world
and thank you for all that you're
putting out there now if anyone's
watching
in the vffs or at home and you want to
vote for me to try
a special talent or just be goofy or
learn
something or put in some bizarre
interesting scenario
right into our show and go to our show's
website
and vote for drew does and you know what
i'll try anything
you